I loved this toothbrush so much for myself.
I got one for my boyfriend too.
I love it. This.
I like his better actually, because it's a little bit bigger.
But look, it has all the different settings. It's for. You can whiten,
clean, soft polish or gum care.
Can you hear it?
It's just this like, little sonic brush.
And it cleans your teeth so good.
I was with a really shitty partner for a really long time.
He used to make me feel really self conscious about my teeth.
He would be like,
oh my god, could you stop talking? Cause your fucking breath.
But it was just his fucking manipulation to get me to shut up.
So I've always been really paranoid about my teeth.
But this fucking.
These toothbrushes right here.
This toothbrush.
This toothbrush,
I love it. Very worth it.
ADA accepted. And it comes with enough.
Enough replacement heads for two years.
Highly recommend.